welcome to Carnegie Mellon University at
Davos where we live at that was were
joined live at Davos by two of the nine
faculty members that the university has
over at the World Economic Forum
presenting to the forum itself and at a
number of private events it's a it's a
great contingent and we're very excited
to have a few moments of time from two
of our professors Chris Harrison
assistant professor of human-computer
interaction and director of the future
interfaces group and Anthony rope
associate professor of Electrical and
Computer Engineering and a member of
Scilab Chris's research includes work on
wearable computing touch interfaces and
gestural interaction Anthony's research
work he works on networked real-time
embedded systems and more recently on
how new systems interact with the
environment so thank you gentlemen for
joining us from snowy Davos we're here
in I'm here in snowy Pittsburgh and
we're glad to have a few moments of your
time I wonder if each of you could spend
just a couple of moments telling us
about what you've been telling the
sorted business and government and
education leaders gathered there in
Davos Chris do you want to start us off
yeah sure so actually Carnegie Mellon
just presented its ideas lab this
yesterday on connected sensors and their
implications with the promise and peril
of those sensors as they get deployed
out into the world so we know that unit
of things is this leaked hot area
industries buying into it policies women
rounded in government and seeing me was
really at the technical center of that
progress until we gave our presentations
and business leaders many CEOs in the
repulsive people in public policy to
start informing them about those Trenton
transformative technologies that's great
Anthony what were you talking about
though I was sort of on The Herald side
effects include robot matthew lasar on
the promise in Africa Stockton Errol so
I talked about security group connected
sensor so how do we protect these
devices what are the implications
the restoration not only now just going
to become wild but things that are
actually going to be equal as great well
those are rich topics and ones I want to
delve into in a minute or two one little
bit of housekeeping for those of us who
may be watching the live stream here you
are welcome to ask questions of Chris
and Anthony via Twitter we're going to
use the hashtag CMU at wef CMU at wef
that's spelling out at CMU 80 wef send
your questions I will read them off and
ask the gentleman to address them why
don't we start Chris I'd like to go back
to a conversation you and I had briefly
before you left for Switzerland which
you were helping me understand some of
your work and what I took away from that
is that those of us lay people tend to
think about technological innovation as
the gizmo where we're entirely focused
on the new gizmo where a lot of research
is now going on to how human beings
interact with their kids Mo's and I mean
that in the in the most concrete way how
do we touch our devices to the broadest
way how do we keep our information
secure that sort of thing is that is
that where the the research is headed I
mean certainly there is a lot of
research going on in that area that
there's obviously tremendous advances
still to be made in the hardware of
computing but we know increasingly than
the interaction it all makes these
devices really special if you look at us
or the success of the iphone the
hardware was very nifty but that
interaction layer on top of it is really
what cemented smartphones as this
indispensable device today so kind of at
a very high level we know that humans
are very fast in their own way computers
are very fast in their own way we know
that the interactions between the two
are kind of slow in this slow right now
and so there's an entire department
actually at Carnegie Mellon University
the human-computer interaction Institute
but it's essentially to armin I'm with a
25 faculty that are researching how to
make better work
pleasurable more efficient interface and
what would be an example of that in your
work so one of the kind of threads of
research in my work recently has been
this notion is sort of developing new
touch technologies beyond multi-touch so
you're the iphone which were they
brought multi-touch the popularity was
about you know eight years ago when that
first day the iphone one was about eight
years ago and multi-touch ruby hasn't
tremendously evolved since then and so
what we've been working on in the lab
for about the past five year is the sort
of what does multi-touch two point oh
look like are we still going to be using
the pinching and poking at our phones in
10 or 20 years or as their new
modalities for a touch interaction that
we haven't even yet underneath exploited
or really understand and so we've been
working on what we call rich touch
technologies as opposed to use multi
touch technologies a sort of unlocking
explore that puter what tease us a
little bit what might some of this rich
touch look like what would you do so
right now multi-touch which is why it's
called multi-touch is really all about
counting the number of fingers on the
screen hence the multi and what we want
to see is actually sort of the shape of
the hand on the screen what parts of the
hand or touching the screen sir for
example the fingertip or the knuckle of
a nail or stylus i'm also the angle that
the finger approaches the screen so not
just a cutie touch plane but actually
the three-dimensional angle sort of the
vector of the finger on that touch
screen and as you learn all these
different dimensions of touch together
you begin to unlock a touch experience
that's much more like the real world how
you might write with a pen on a piece of
paper or paint on a canvas or even just
pick up your cup to drink some coffee we
don't do that by poking you know our
fingers at it we do that by using our
hands in a much more holistic way are
these things we're going to see any time
soon in our smartphones yes in fact one
of the technologies has already been
commercialized and spun out of the
university as a start-up which is based
both in pittsburgh and in Silicon Valley
though already these technologies are
escaping the lab and I know we have many
more of these technologies that are soon
gonna find their ways on the smartphone
but I can tell you about all those
things they're there in discussion right
now looking forward to it Anthony you
you look at how computers and humans
interface and a whole
different way and recognizing that it's
not always the the next cool thing but
that as you mentioned there are there
are some dangers and threats that I
think we're becoming increasingly aware
of talk a little bit about where your
work is particularly in that realm
here's on I'm a little bit lower down on
the stack is in the hood or the crista
so we look at sort of the platforms and
protocols that allow you to collect rich
sensor information so for example we
want to put devices in a room tell you
something that will have to complete
play about the light intensity pattern
called how do we actually meet those
missions deployables how do we make it
so that they can actually live or multi
layers on batteries and then listen
portly especially here in the context of
goblets how do we make that secures and
break into these devices so we develop
some of the hardware we develop a little
bit of operating system that runs on
those types of devices we also look at
the communication protocols for how they
actually exchange information with other
how they bring it back to human systems
and by collecting information from a
bunch of different sources there's a
critical whole space where we can look
at processing data streams to tell you
more about a state where we begin with
just one of these individual devices so
if I understand what you're talking
about you mean that it's not just my
computer and my phone and my iPad that
are tracking me but my thermostat and
that funny-looking antenna on the light
pole on some cameras that I'm not seeing
and that this stuff is all picking up
information presumably at different
levels of sophistication to yes and
feeding it to who knows where yeah i
mean we're used to seeing our laptops
and phones which are actually quite
quite capable compute life words like we
have to charge them every day right we
know that our phone doesn't have a
battery life is something like your
device's the thermostat they leave on
well forever so there is kind of this
discrepancy how much computing the quick
very low and people is attained to make
them practical but you're seeing
computation pushed into know many many
many different vendors aspects of you
learn so it's beyond just hopefully the
next cause leaders will be on me beyond
just what we see
day you can start to steam compute
communication and hold your different
connected appliances other aspects of
your life your car communicating and and
how do we begin to approach being safe
in this welter of stuff that's sending
our information around our their
standards are we trying to develop
standards or there's been a lot of
discussion about standards here right
now that really aren't that many of
their taking the lead there are
standards and communication protocols
that do include some level of security
you approach the we've been taking a
theme you that's computers has really
been kind of a living laboratory
philosophy we want to push out a bunch
of these devices we want to see what we
can do with them and then we also want
to look at security implications and the
privacy implications insert realistic
settings so when you are sitting
together on a panel that must be a
fascinating experience I don't imagine
that most of your academic conference
work would necessarily have you sitting
side by side what is it like to be
sitting in a room full of frankly power
brokers there in Davos what are you
learning from each other what are you
hearing from them i'm just interested in
getting a sense of the flavor of the
room so i mean even though me and
anthony are not even in different
departments but actually differing
schools nonetheless we actually do
collaborate on projects together i'm
even though we built the pin at CMU not
immune from the longest I'm a relatively
new faculty but that's really one of the
hallmarks of CMU is that
interdisciplinary approaches to our work
so meaning they have worked on research
together before with respect that kind
of attendees at Davos but i think is
most intriguing to me and nothing about
anthony if that it brings a very
different perspective these aren't even
just necessarily ordinary users but
these are people but we were just in the
session literally half an hour ago with
the the Prime Minister of Canada Justin
to know and in hearing his remarks and
trying to understand how in a public
policy and also government laws shape
the intervention and use of technology
is really interesting that's unless
you're feeling this sort of those power
brokers as you say and hearing their
perspective not just even sort of the
citizens perspectives but how the
implementation actually gets done is
really
interesting and if giving me certainly
new insights I think there's there's
generally a lot of excitement industrial
porno revolution Spencer's but at the
same time what are these risks what have
you learned from each other as you're
either sitting on a panel or walking
down the streets of Davos anything you
heard in the last couple of days that
sparked a new interest in your work that
you heard from one of your colleagues
they even get some of the most
interesting people who connection and I
mean there's a some of my work is
focused on during doing electrification
in rural environments that seems to be a
pretty popular topic here there's a lot
of discussion about refugee camps and
how we can actually make them more
livable we all give life there as well
as just there is a fair amount of
excitement in looking at how technology
will improve those those types of
problems um I guess from person I
collaborating together we've definitely
seen a lot of overlap some of the typo
division that first ones in your
interfaces then looking at it from my
perspective like technology that is you
make such an important point you know I
think it's easy for those of us who are
not in your business to sometimes get a
little lost in terminology it feels
abstract it feels futuristic it feels
unconnected to daily life but the work
you're both doing is deeply connected to
the most important challenges that face
us and sometimes in very direct ways
this year as you're pointing out that's
exciting to me so I appreciate your
mentioning that we do have a question
from Twitter this is from Gabe rahay
brahim now I'm getting that wrong but
it's a long twitter handle who is asking
MIT economist
artificial intelligence will be the
first technological advancement that
won't create new jobs do you agree and
if that's true what does that mean for
the economy that's not quite fair to ask
you this economist but any reaction when
you hear talk like that I mean I think
everyone has their own take because even
though AI has been around as a field for
a while it's burning to see really
powerful practical uses a lot of major
companies now putting it the hard work
and we're seeing it be really
transformative now that it sort of
migrated from academia into practice
everyone's going every time you do a
voice search AI is powering that voice
recognition so we're seeing almost on a
daily basis now it wasn't through ten
years ago but I would say yes maybe
there is a threat to kind of appending
those jobs but that would be a very
short time a kind of short-term loss and
every time we've student really
disruptive technology come for example a
no on you 100 years ago 200 years ago
the United States ninety-seven percent
the population was farming and you might
have said the lib mechanization we lost
all those farming jobs but clearly here
with a three percent of people that are
involved in agriculture in the u.s.
today is that a bad thing or should we
all go back to farming with you know
pitchforks and rakes so clearly that was
a benefit and the same thing happened
with industrial revolution and things
like textiles of moon every single time
there's really been an efficiently game
in the workforce and industry it's freed
up jobs but people have gone on to do
better jobs and I think that he will be
in AI is going to replace a lot of those
sort of low-level or mid-level jobs
people to be more creative and
intelligent things and I think in the
long run this will be a great benefit
met on yeah and I think that's all
summed up in what the World Economic
Forum choses its theme for this year the
fourth Industrial Revolution there are
no industrial revolutions that have
reduced the number of jobs available and
as I look at my window here in
Pittsburgh and i watch the immense
amount of growth that's going on around
the the new ideas artificial
intelligence and other new technologies
that are being developed through
Carnegie Mellon research and others
seems pretty clear that at least in the
short term there some new new jobs being
created
definitely go we have we're about 15
minutes in you have both been very
generous with your time and I appreciate
it I imagine you have more activities to
go through before the evening is over
but I just wanted to give you one last
chance if there's anything that you saw
or heard or reflected that you think
those of us back in the States or
elsewhere around the world would be
interested in hearing a moment to close
it out it gets extremely high energy
right now yeah and its greatest news
theme you have a presence on the
international stage and be able to be
participate as a palm reader and some of
the universally I think that make 12 in
the united states that are participating
and see you as one of them given only
eight but a handful of universities that
are invited to participate here and
share their ideas and it's really
exciting print don't the bus i think
different isn't it and have such amazing
people in this evening sessions must be
able to discuss opportunity from the
halls that's that's right and as you
both said to not only to be
interdisciplinary in the sense of
crossing academic disciplines but to
engage with government leaders business
leaders and make sure that that research
is really having the social benefit that
i know is it the heart of why you do
what you do so with that I think we're
going to thank you gentlemen both
grateful for your time enjoy the rest of
your time in Davos and looking forward
to seeing you back in Pittsburgh yes
likewise thanks everybody